all right Jeremy hi Jeremy where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm from Syracuse New York
Upstate Syracuse New York you still live
there I still live there I moved back
I moved away for a while moved back to
pursue different things
um but yeah I'm from Syracuse New York
originally and
um
I grew up with my parents both Mom and
Dad uh unconditional love they're really
cool and I appreciate them but
um I think you know I've always felt
different
I don't know how to explain that except
that I felt different
um growing up alone I was isolated by my
peers
um
and it was really hard
uh one of that become noticeable for you
as far back as I can remember always
always
um anxiety anxiety mood swings which I
didn't understand obviously then you
know I didn't know they were mood swings
I just thought they were like
that I was just you know sensitive
that's what people would say they're
like oh he's just extra sensitive
and um I would freak out at teachers I'd
freak out at people
um just which now I know is me becoming
manic
and having a manic episode
um which I learned way too late in life
um saw a doctor and got diagnosed yeah I
saw a doctor I've been diagnosed
um I've I've seen multiple doctors uh
because
I haven't had the right medicine yet uh
now I'm on the right medicine but it
took two years to get the right medicine
like there has been times where I was
either a zombie or I was just completely
out of it how long did it go before you
saw a doctor
uh until I was like 29. oh really so all
through High School you were I was it
was horrible
um in high school I just was like
I was like singled out my whole class
singled me out
um I was different
because I guess I just reacted
differently than everybody else
and I was just an easy target
so that's that's really what it came
down to you know like someone who has
like a flaw of people will
especially younger kids they'll pick it
out and they'll they'll just like make
you feel
as bad as possible because that's just
how it is growing up
um but then I got to college hey
college is great
College was college is great because I
got to experience a lot of different
people
and I I got to experience uh different
um
professors that were amazing that taught
me
a lot of different like ways of thinking
and everything like that
um I was still really depressed I know I
was I I didn't realize it at the time
if that makes sense like in it
but I was going through like waves and
and I was still dealing with like
uh friends that would become my friends
and then quickly like they would they
would like
think I'm too much
you were having episodes up and down up
and down all the time
um and at that time
uh
right before College I was diagnosed
with uh Crohn's
so that was really rough
um actually uh the Crohn's and it didn't
come to
complete
fruition that I would find out later on
that like uh
getting Crohn's was because of my mental
illness
and they said that later on that because
I had mental illness that it causes the
ulcers and causes all the problems
so that was super interesting
and what were you finally diagnosed with
um it's good so effective
what is that exactly it's basically
extreme bipolar
um I I I'm on medicine now for it I
smoke a lot of weed
um
it's
basically me getting really too Manic
and and too freaked out and my first
time that
when I was diagnosed with it I was given
a lot of Xanax
a lot of it
like candy
and they just told me take the little
ones when you felt anxious
I kept taking them
and I would take them until I just
wanted to be like not there anymore
and
it was the only thing that I found like
any salvation in
and at the same time when I was on that
I had painkillers prescribed to me too
and I was taking those way too much
and everything at once was like hitting
me and I wasn't feeling myself and I
just I really just I
I wanted to die
how serious did that get
I um
I took a bunch of Xanax one night
um you know and some painkillers and I
just didn't want to wake up in the
morning
and I woke up
and I was like oh my God I think I I
need to go get help and so I told my
wife that
I really wasn't feeling good and that
what I was planning on doing and she
called an Uber and I went and I I went
in to a psychiatric ward
and when I was in there I was around a
lot of crazy I hate to say that word
that's horrible obviously but I was
around a lot of just like
people that were dealing with a lot of
similar things
and it made me feel less alone which was
really cool
and they had programs I went through
programs
and
it was really hard to get off of Xanax
way too hard
um but I did
and then they prescribed me other
medicine and now I'm on an
antidepressant antipsychotic and I'm on
similar drugs that people have leukemia
for my Crohn's and that's for the rest
of my life and you're doing better I'm
doing great now personally and I am very
thankful for having a great support
system I've stayed in programs
I am working on myself the best that I
personally can
um
and I think that
you have to like find it within you to
do that
sorry I
it's not easy like I literally want a
Xanax right now
I'm trying not to I'm trying not to even
puff on The Vape I'm really like I'm
trying to just talk and I know it's not
easy and I'm like really really trying
right now did your wife struggle through
some of these ups and downs she has
struggled so much
she's a trooper
do you know how many times cops have
gotten called on me
I've never been arrested but the cops
have been called on me and they don't
think that there's like
a manic episode they'll think I'm like
on drugs
which is like really [__] up are you
using drugs as well I just smoke weed
yeah yeah that's it I've never done any
like hard drugs I've never like you
behave like it sometimes do I no no but
I don't I don't know you but but I
assume if you're extreme bipolar
schizoaffective you're probably behaving
like a
yeah
make somebody cops come in they've had
their hands on their guns like and I'm
just like are you [__] serious I
literally will be in a manic episode so
I'll just be freaking out on them
I don't mean to
it's not like something I'm sitting
there like oh yeah come on
let's have a good old time you know what
I mean can't control it can't control it
um
knock on wood there's no buttons knock
on wood I'm I'm doing well so far I
haven't like freaked out I was on this
trip I'm doing well I have support
system with me on my trip I have
support system anywhere I go uh just in
case it's only been a few years that
you've been
medicated yes how old are you now I am
32. 32. yep so your friends kind of knew
what was going on with you
no
I kept a lot to myself
but
the closest friends I've told and this
is the first time me sharing this
really I mean my family knows
some of my family knows
but I can guarantee you there's somebody
watching this who's probably going
through something very similar and they
don't know what to do about it yeah
I hope so your life improved
since you were diagnosed and medicated
correctly yes uh everything is way
better now I'm like
I'm a dad I'm sorry I forgot to share
I'm a dad full-time dad
that's what I do
I'm a full-time dad I love it two years
old
she's the best thing she's amazing
and uh that's what I do is I I stay with
my daughter I stay home with my daughter
and I do art your wife works my wife
works yeah I mean I make money from my
art
but it's
not we're
I'm an artist
what the heck do you want from me you
know what I mean it's not like you make
money off of art I try
I do the best I can I draw paint music
everything movies what are the downsides
of your new medicated self
okay sometimes when I manic I can do
things
I feel like
that's true
I got on Warped Tour
because I was super Manic
and it was like 3 A.M in the night time
and I emailed the guy who like runs it
and I was like I'm in this band I'm not
anymore I was like I was in this band I
was like please put us on this blah blah
blah I gave my story and everything like
that and he was like all right
I was like whoa that's cool
but
that's rare
when I'm mad sometimes I feel like a
superhero
like dead serious
is that weird no
I've seen I've seen people behave like
that a lot yeah
I feel like I can do anything
but no I'm I'm just I'm just me and I'm
like it came it was a lot to to become
comfortable as me
it was really hard
it was really all I'm sorry I'm in touch
with Mike
um I just it took a lot to be
comfortable as me
and if people don't like me I just kind
of just go all right whatever it is what
it is there's a lot of people out there
that that are my friends and they do
accept me for who I am and the people
that don't anymore
that's up to them
you're
instability
kept you from having a lot of close
relationships
yeah
um
anytime I got close
I would just like people would just like
judge me
dang
you know it's crazy I do therapy
every Monday I thought I was prepared to
talk about all of this and it's just so
interesting now like actually sitting
here going through it in my head
because
I was literally
made to feel like I was nothing for
years
by who everybody
all my peers my parents were great
though my dad worked a lot
um my mom was there but they I don't
think they really like were
understanding of what was going on a lot
of people told me it was um
it was hormones
[Music]
a lot of people told me it was hormones
and and that's crazy
but
unfortunately it's just as the thing in
my head and I'm doing much better with
my my Crohn's colitis everything is
doing great my
everything everything is like been great
ever since I've been diagnosed and been
on the right medicine for my brain I
only have to be on one pill now for my
my autoimmune disease which before I was
on a lot of other medicine which was
crazy too
but
yeah I mean
I'm doing much better I'm I'm very
thankful you giving me this time
to share my story because I think that
if somebody out there is dealing with
this too they can get help what do you
wish you had done earlier
seek help or the problem is is that
there I don't think there was help
or if there was help I didn't know about
it
someone if someone told me about it
information about these kind of things
just in general I didn't know about like
therapy
I didn't know about therapy I didn't
know about like
I know about getting like medicine to
help you but the problem is that you
have to get the right medicine
because I was on the wrong medicine I
almost died on it
so
yeah
that's
I mean
I've done so much now like I I now use
my art to get out all of my
whatevers when I'm feeling a certain way
if I feel manic I know it I go out I
smoke
and I'll work on something and that'll
stabilize you yeah whether it's
a painting or a song
or just
anything
I just sit there and I I try my hardest
to just get it out that way and it's
it's very therapeutic and and I think
with the mixture of the right medicine
and with therapy and with my art I'm I'm
doing much better
that's cool
I'm thankful
you're happier now I'm so much happier I
really am I honestly have Still Moments
where I get in a manic episode
but it's nothing like
when I'm on my medicine
give me an example of how bad it would
get when you were unmedicated
unmedicated to the point where I'm in a
closet bleeding on the ground like
because I just caught myself
I have a cop coming in and I'm like
rolling on the ground saying like I want
to go to outer space
that's some real [__] I've never shared
that before
but yeah
I was like on the phone with my dad and
I was talking to him and I was just like
he's just like you're not my son we're
not like when that's going on I'm like I
know
is there anybody else in your family
that had
similar behaviors
I don't know
that's really interesting I know a lot
of my family but like there's some
family I just don't know that well
and I would love to know
that would be really cool
and I'm wondering if that's like
something I can look up
what's your biggest fear now
being alone
because I like push everybody away from
me because of like my mental illness
I still am afraid of that
like
it's not easy being around me
sometimes
and I try my hardest to be as calm and
Collective as possible
and just chill that's probably the
hardest thing of people that have these
kind of mental illnesses is what they
need most is
connection but they behave in a way that
pushes people away
yeah
huh
that sucks
but
how long have you been married
um ready for this
2014.
the math on that would be 12 years I've
been with her nine years yes but I've
been over there for 12 years okay
I know that off the top of my head
College sweetheart she wrote through
seven ups and downs with you
it's not Road dog
lover
she's amazing she's been there for
everything it's not easy
even this morning I was like a little
like all over the place and she was just
like can you get your [__] together and
I was like I know
I know I know and I had this all planned
out like what I was gonna say and I've
completely gone off track
okay you're doing good you're doing
great
I'm trying man I I literally am very
just like
all right I'm good now
I'm better than I was
thank God for the medications right
yeah man
God ish you know
I think the universe
Jeremy what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this journey of yours being very
thankful for everything
I'm so happy I'm Not Dead
true statement
if I could get anything out of this I'm
so happy I'm Not Dead
I'm like happy to be alive I'm happy to
be here right now
I'm happy to be doing this
I'm just happy to be
in the city I'm happy to be
a dad and a husband
it's cool
that's great yeah man all right Jerry
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you I appreciate it good luck with
your daughter and everything else
appreciate you thank you
God I hope I did well
it is